This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. When Nelson Mandela became South Africa's first black president in 1994, he had big dreams for his bitterly divided country. We and our inter-government, that we shall build a society, a rainbow nation, at peace with itself and the world. He had spent a lifetime fighting the racist apartheid regime, including more than a quarter century in prison. He was a heroic figure already by that time.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维达姆塔姆。1994年，当纳尔逊·曼德拉成为南非首位黑人总统时，他对这个严重分裂的国家抱有宏伟的梦想。我们与我们的跨政府部门，我们将建设一个社会，一个彩虹之国，与自己及世界和平相处。他用一生时间对抗种族隔离政权，其中包括在监狱度过的二十多年。在那时，他已经是一个英雄般的人物。
But to many white South Africans, they saw him as a criminal and a terrorist. This is psychologist, J. Van Bevel. As president of the United South Africa, Nelson Mandela or Mediba, as he was known to his supporters, needed to find a way for the people in his rainbow nation to see themselves as South Africans first. Other politicians might have turned to speeches and policies.
但在许多白人南非人眼中，他被视为罪犯和恐怖分子。这是心理学家J·范贝维尔。作为南非总统，纳尔逊·曼德拉（支持者称他为马迪巴）需要为彩虹之国的人民找到一种方法，让他们首先把自己视为南非人。其他政治家可能会求助于演讲和政策。
Mediba turned to sports. Placid continues, off side by New Zealand. He used the Rudby World Cup, which was being hosted in South Africa. And during the apartheid era, South Africa had been banned from competition. And the South African team was known as the Spring Box, and they were beloved by the white South Africans and despised by the black population. But what Mandela did was he went out into the podium, not just as the president, but as a fan he
马迪巴转向了体育。新西兰队边路突破，比赛继续。他利用了在南非举办的橄榄球世界杯。在种族隔离时期，南非曾被禁止参赛。南非队被称为“跳羚队”，白人南非人对其爱戴有加，而黑人群体则对之鄙视。但曼德拉所做的是，他走上领奖台，不仅仅是以总统的身份，而是作为一个球迷，他
had the Green Springboks cap in Jersey. And he used it as a way to make a statement that we're one team, we're one country now, and he took a symbol of oppression and used it as a symbol of togetherness. The president to the captain. The Springboks team captain, Francois Pinar, remembers the moment Madiba walked into the team's locker room. It was before the finals against New Zealand. He said, good luck boys and they turned around.
戴着绿色的跳羚队帽子，穿着球衣。他以此发表声明：我们现在是一个团队，是一个国家，他把压迫的象征变成了团结的象征。总统对队长。跳羚队队长弗朗索瓦·皮纳尔回忆起马迪巴走进球队更衣室的那一刻。那是在对阵新西兰的决赛之前。他说，祝你们好运，小伙子们，然后他们转过身去。
And my number was on his back and that was me. I couldn't see the anthem because I knew I would cry. I was just so proud to be South Africa that day. The match was a nail-biter. It went into overtime. South Africa ended up winning 15-12. Across the country, black and white South Africans cheered together in triumph. Trump's weapon, Nelson Mandela, is cheering along with the whole of the stadium.
我的号码在他的背上，那正是我。我无法唱出国歌，因为我知道自己会哭。那天我为身为南非人感到无比骄傲。这场比赛扣人心弦。比赛进入了加时赛。南非最终以15比12获胜。全国各地的黑人和白人南非人一起欢呼胜利。特朗普的武器纳尔逊·曼德拉正与全场观众一起欢呼。
The sea flags. Nelson Mandela knew that getting enemies to cheer for the same sports team was only a start. Much work remained to heal the wounds of apartheid. But his intervention reveal how a psychologically astute leader can find ways to create connections among people. Even better enemies. This week on Hidden Brain, how group identities bring us together,
挥舞的旗帜。纳尔逊·曼德拉深知，让敌对双方为同一支运动队欢呼仅仅是个开始。要治愈种族隔离的创伤，还有大量工作要做。但他的干预表明，一个具心理洞察力的领导人如何能找到在人们之间建立联系的方法。甚至是死敌。本周的Hidden Brain节目将探讨群体认同如何将我们凝聚在一起、
tear us apart, and transform our understanding of the world. When we think about what we do and why we do it, we often assume we are acting intentionally and autonomously. I do something because I want to do it. I choose to do it. In recent years, social scientists have shown that this is often not true. Our actions, our preferences, the very way we see the world, is filtered through the
将我们分化，并重塑我们对世界的理解。当我们思考我们做了什么以及为什么这样做时，我们常常假设我们的行为是有意且自主的。我做某事是因为我想做。我选择这样做。近年来，社会科学家表明这往往并非事实。我们的行为、我们的偏好，甚至我们看待世界的方式，都经过了
prism of our group identities. This idea has fascinated Javan Bavill for a long time. He's a psychologist at New York University. He has studied how our group loyalties pull us together, how they tear us apart, and how we can apply what we have learned about the science of group identity to build better lives and better communities. Javan Bavill, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. science of group identity to build better lives and better communities. J. Van Bevel, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me.
群体认同这一棱镜的过滤。这个想法长期以来一直令J·范贝维尔着迷。他是纽约大学的心理学家。他研究了我们的群体忠诚如何将我们凝聚在一起、如何将我们分裂，以及我们如何能够将关于群体认同科学的认知应用于构建更好的生活和更好的社区。J·范贝维尔，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。谢谢邀请我。群体认同科学的认知应用于构建更好的生活和更好的社区。J·范贝维尔，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。谢谢邀请我。
I want to start by talking about some of the ways in which our group identities can draw us together with other people, J. You grew up in Canada. And I understand your parents told you to sow the Canadian national flag onto your backpack. Did you ever find yourself bonding with other Canadians when you traveled overseas? Yeah, so this is a great piece of advice you learn if you're ever going to travel in Canada. Your family, your friends will tell you to sew a Canadian flag on your backpack so that it serves as a signal to other people in other parts of the world who you are and where you're from.
我想从我们的群体认同如何将我们与其他人拉近的几种方式开始，J。你在加拿大长大。据我所知，你的父母让你把加拿大国旗缝在背包上。你在海外旅行时有没有发现自己和其他加拿大人产生过共鸣？是的，如果你要在加拿大旅行，这是你会学到的一条极好的建议。你的家人、朋友会告诉你在背包上缝一面加拿大旗帜，这样它就能向世界其他地方的人发出信号，表明你是谁、你来自哪里。
Canada is a reasonably well-liked and respected country, but it does something even better, which is it allows you to connect with people. So I was actually in my first-ever international trip in high school, and we were in Venice, you know, one of the most beautiful, interesting cities in the world, some of the best food in the world. And I was a Canadian teenager, so I found the first McDonald's that I've seen in probably a week. And I wandered in and I'm in line to get some chicken nuggets. And this young teenage girl comes up and just starts talking to me in English. And it quickly dawned on me that she saw that I had a Canadian maple leaf on a sweater that I was wearing. And so it was her way of seeing that we shared this in common.
加拿大是一个相当受欢迎且受尊敬的国家，但它做了一件甚至更好的事情，那就是它能让你与人建立联系。事实上，我在高中时进行了第一次国际旅行，当时我们在威尼斯，你知道，这是世界上最美丽、最有趣的城市之一，拥有世界上最棒的一些美食。我当时是个十几岁的加拿大少年，所以我找到了我可能一个星期以来见过的第一家麦当劳。我走了进去，在排队买鸡块。这时一个十几岁的小女孩走过来，直接用英语跟我说话。我很快意识到，她看到我穿的毛衣上有一个加拿大的枫叶标志。所以这是她发现我们有共同点的一种方式。
And if I was anywhere in Canada, I doubt she would have come up and started talking to me. But since we were all the way around the world, that identity was something that bonded us in an unfamiliar situation. Yeah, so that's fascinating because of course, as you just pointed out, if you were both in Toronto or Ottawa, the fact that you were both Canadians would have been utterly unremarkable. But in Venice, that portion of your identities stood out. Yeah, so it turns out that one of the most powerful ways to trigger an identity is to be a minority in a situation.
如果我在加拿大的任何地方，她不太可能走过来跟我说话。但既然我们远在世界另一端在一个不熟悉的环境中，那个身份就成了将我们联系在一起纽带。是的，这很吸引人，正如你刚才所指出的，如果你俩都在多伦多或渥太华，你们俩都是加拿大人这一事实将完全微不足道。但在威尼斯，你身份的那一部分就突显出来了。是的，事实证明，触发身份认同最强大的方法之一就是在某种情况下成为少数群体。
When you're all surrounded by fellow Canadians, you're not thinking about yourself for the most part in terms of being a Canadian, but it's really powerful when you're both, you know, in a foreign land. That thing that might otherwise be really mundane becomes really significant to you. We've all had experiences like this. We know what it's like to be part of a group, to belong to a club.
当你周围都是加拿大同胞时，你在很大程度上不会以身为加拿大人来思考自己，但当你们俩都在异国他乡时，这种感觉非常强大。那些在平时可能非常平凡的事情对你来说变得意义重大。我们都有过这样的经历。我们知道成为一个群体的一部分、属于一个俱乐部是什么感觉。
As a psychologist, Jay has discovered that our group identities are more than a source of connection. They tell us what we should care about. I ran this study in Ottawa, which is the capital of Canada, in collaboration with a colleague who was a professor at Carlton University, and he set up a table in the Byward market, which is kind of a famous old market in Ottawa.
作为一名心理学家，J发现我们的群体认同不仅仅是联系的源泉。它们告诉我们应该关心的事物。我在加拿大首都渥太华进行了这项研究，与卡尔顿大学的一位教授同事合作，他在拜沃德市场（渥太华一个著名的老市场）摆了一张桌子。
And he pulled people who were walking by and offered them a choice between taste test. They were able to sample honey or maple syrup. And then we randomly flipped a coin and assigned people to one of two conditions. Half of the people were primed to think about their personal identity. So they talked about like books they liked
他拦住路过的人，让他们在味觉测试中做出选择。他们可以品尝蜂蜜或枫糖浆。然后我们随机抛硬币，将人们分配到两种情况之一。一半的人被引导去思考他们的个人身份。所以他们谈论像他们喜欢的书
as an individual. The other half of the people were primed to think about their Canadian identity. And what we found is that when they were primed with their individual identity, they tended to like the taste of honey and maple syrup roughly the same. But when they were primed with their individual identity, they tended to like the taste of honey and maple syrup, roughly the same, but when they were primed with their Canadian identity, they liked the maple syrup more than the honey. And so what it suggests is that when your identity is salient, it makes
作为一个个体。另一半人被引导去思考他们的加拿大身份。我们发现，当他们被灌输个体身份时，他们对蜂蜜和枫糖浆的味道大致同样喜爱。但当他们被灌输个体身份时，他们对蜂蜜和枫糖浆的味道大致同样喜爱，而当他们被灌输加拿大身份时，他们比蜂蜜更喜欢枫糖浆。这表明，当你的身份凸显时，它会使
you prefer things that are associated with that identity. And for Canada, maple syrup is one of the big ones. We literally have the Maple Leaf on our national flag. We have a strategic national reserve of maple syrup. So Canada takes maple syrup pretty seriously. So companies that are smart about group identity can sometimes use this to spur sales. Tell me what Moulson Breweries did in their IAM Canadian ad. When I was a teenager, Moulson Breweries,
你更喜欢与该身份相关的事物。对加拿大来说，枫糖浆是最重要的事物之一。我们的国旗上 literalmente（字面意思）有枫叶。我们有枫糖浆的战略国家储备。因此，加拿大对枫糖浆相当严肃。所以那些对群体认同敏感的公司有时可以利用这一点来促进销售。告诉我莫尔森啤酒公司在“我是加拿大人”广告中做了什么。当我十几岁的时候，莫尔森啤酒公司，
which is one of the biggest beer brewery in the entire country, came up with this really incredible ad, and it's just this guy walks on stage. There was a teenager, Moulson Brewery, which is one of the biggest beer brewery in the entire country, came up with this really incredible ad, and it's just this guy walks on stage. Hey, I'm not a lumberjack or a fur trader, and I don't live in any glue or eat lumber or own a dog sled. And he just goes on this rant about what it means to be Canadian, and in particular how it's different from an American.
作为全国最大的啤酒厂之一，推出了这个非常不可思议的广告，内容就是一个家伙走上舞台。当时还是个青少年的莫尔森啤酒厂，作为全国最大的啤酒厂之一，推出了这个非常不可思议的广告，内容就是一个家伙走上舞台。嘿，我不是伐木工或毛皮商人，我不住在冰屋里，不吃木材，也没有狗拉雪橇。他只是滔滔不绝地谈论成为加拿大人意味着什么，尤其是它与美国人有何不同。
I have a Prime Minister, not a President. I speak English and French, not American, and I pronounce it about. It had a Canadian flag flying in the background to talk about hockey being the national support. So all these things that Canadians really cherish is part of who they are and part of their culture. And Canadians often don't have a very strong sense of identity and this ad captured it. The field is a coach. And an ace pronounced said, not Zed! Zed! Canada is the second largest landmass,
我有总理，没有总统。我说英语和法语，不说美式英语，而且我把about发音为...。背景中飘扬着一面加拿大国旗，谈到曲棍球是国民运动。所以所有这些加拿大人真正珍视的东西都是他们身份和文化的一部分。加拿大人往往没有很强的身份认同感，而这个广告捕捉到了这一点。球场是个教练。而且王牌发音是said，不是Zed！是Zed！加拿大是第二大陆地面积，
the first nation in working, and the best part of America. My name is Joe, and I am Canadian. And this ad, you know, won a number of awards because it signaled to Canadians something really important, like who am I? But at the same time, it also increased sales very dramatically for Moulson Brewery because it resonated with people's national identity.
劳动的第一民族，也是美国最好的部分。我叫乔，我是加拿大人。你知道，这则广告赢得了多个奖项，因为它向加拿大人发出了一个非常重要的信号，比如我是谁？但与此同时，它也极大地促进了莫尔森啤酒公司的销量，因为它与人们的国家认同产生了共鸣。
Group identities can influence the beer we drink, the cars we drive, the clothes we wear. But they can also do something even more significant. They can shape our basic perceptions. What we see here even smell. I asked Jay about a study out of the University of Sussex involving a very stinky t-shirt. This has to be one of my favorite studies. Yeah, so this was Ron in the UK and they wanted to see how identity might shape our smell.
群体认同可以影响我们喝的啤酒、开的汽车、穿的衣服。但它们还能做一些更重要的事情。它们可以塑造我们的基本感知。我们看到、听到甚至闻到的东西。我问J关于萨塞克斯大学的一项研究，涉及一件非常臭的T恤。这一定是我最喜欢的研究之一。是的，这是在英国进行的，他们想看看身份认同如何塑造我们的嗅觉。
And so they used a very clever trick to manipulate people's social identity. And then they had them smell the stinky shirt, which they had had a research assistant wear this shirt for like a week sweating in it, exercising in it, not taking it off, and then they put it in this like sealed bin, and they had participants come in and smell this shirt. And what they did was they manipulated this shirt so it either had a logo from the rival university, which was the University of Brighton, or the other half the students got to see this with a Sussex, University of Sussex
所以他们用了一个非常聪明的把戏来操纵人们的社会认同。然后让他们闻那件臭衬衫，他们让一个研究助理穿这件衬衫大约一周，在里面出汗、锻炼、不脱下来，然后他们把它放在一个密封的箱子里，让参与者进来闻这件衬衫。他们做的是，他们对这件衬衫进行了手脚，上面要么印有竞争对手大学的标志，也就是布莱顿大学，或者另一半学生看到的是萨塞克斯大学、萨塞克斯大学的
logo. And so what they found is that when people were primed to think that this was an out group member shirt, they thought it was much more disgusting, a much more putrid and odorous, then when they thought that exact same smelling shirt was from a member of their own in-group. And so it suggests that what we find disgusting
标志。他们发现，当人们被灌输认为这是一件外群体成员的衬衫时，他们会觉得它要恶心得多、更加腐臭和难闻，而当他们认为那件气味完全相同的衬衫来自他们自己的内群体成员时，感觉就不同了。这表明我们觉得恶心的东西
is determined also by our identity and who we define as an in-group and out-group. So this is a remarkable study because in some ways I think it's uncontroversial and unsurprising to say that people are loyal to their groups, but I think the surprising insight from this kind of research is that groups don't just tell us what kind of foods to like or which politicians to support, they actually shape the very way we see the world. Yeah, I mean, what we're trying to argue
同样由我们的身份以及我们将谁定义为内群体和外群体所决定。所以这是一项非凡的研究，因为在某种程度上，我认为说人们对自己的群体忠诚是无可争议且并不令人意外的，但我觉得这类研究所带来的令人惊讶的洞察是，群体不仅告诉我们喜欢哪种食物或支持哪位政治家，它们实际上塑造了我们看待世界的视角。是的，我的意思是，我们试图论证的
and what the growing body of research suggests is that these identities are a lens that shape all kinds of our senses. They shape how we're smelling and interpreting smells, what we're seeing, maybe what we're hearing. And so they help provide a way of interpreting information as it comes in through all our senses. a way of interpreting information as it comes in through all our senses.
以及越来越多的研究表明，这些身份是一副塑造我们各种感官的镜头。它们塑造了我们如何闻到气味并解释气味、我们所看到的，也许还有我们所听到的。因此，它们帮助提供了一种通过我们所有的感官输入来解释信息的方式。一种通过我们所有的感官输入来解释信息的方式。
One last example I want to look at about the power of groups to shape how we see and what we see, Jay, you tell the story of the 1966 World Cup soccer finals between England and Germany. What happened during the finals? So this might be one of the most famous and controversial games of all time. In the dying minutes of the match, the jubilant English supporters nerves who were strained to a breaking point. The World Cup was within England's reach. It was tied and it went to extra minutes.
我想看的最后一个关于群体塑造我们如何看以及看到什么的强大的例子，J，你讲述了1966年世界杯足球决赛英格兰对阵德国的故事。决赛期间发生了什么？所以这可能是史上最著名、最具争议的比赛之一。在比赛将要结束的最后几分钟里，狂热的英格兰球迷紧绷的神经已经到了崩溃的边缘。世界杯触手可及。当时比分打平，比赛进入了加时赛。
And there was a shot by this English player. And it went off the crossbar, and it came down and landed very close to the goal line and then bounced out. Goal claimed England. Now No goal protested the Germans. And all the English players celebrated, they thought this was the, you know, World Cup winning goal. The referee consulted the linesman who had been in line with the posts. And goal it was. And there's huge debate over whether that goal actually crossed the line.
这时这个英格兰球员起脚射门。球击中横梁，弹下来落在非常靠近球门线的地方，然后弹了出去。英格兰大喊进球。现在德国人抗议没有进球。所有的英格兰球员都在庆祝，他们认为这就是那个赢得世界杯的进球。裁判咨询了与门柱平齐的边裁。判定进球有效。对于这个球是否真的越过球门线，存在巨大的争论。
And so to this day, there's still controversy about whether this crossed the line. And so what seemed to happen here is that those players wanted to interpret this ball as going over the line and being a winning goal. The German players did not. And so I spent an entire day like watching old videos and slow motion and pausing them to see if the goal
因此直到今天，关于这是否越过球门线仍有争议。这里似乎发生的情况是，那些球员希望将这个球解释为越过了球门线并且是一个制胜球。德国球员则不希望这样。所以我花了一整天的时间看老视频、慢动作并暂停它们，看看这个球
actually crossed the line. I looked up a study from Oxford University saying it didn't cross the line. And so I do not think he scored. It looked like it came down right on the goal line and bounced out. However, the same player scored later and over time. And so England would have won anyways. We see the same things in all kinds of sports all over the world, Jay. Fans of different teams will see different things happen on the field, and each of them is completely sure that what they
是否真的越过了球门线。我查阅了牛津大学的一项研究，说它没有越过球门线。所以我不认为他进球了。它看起来像是直接落在球门线上然后弹了出去。然而，同一个球员在加时赛晚些时候又进球了。所以英格兰无论如何都会赢。我们在世界各地的各种体育运动中都看到了同样的事情，J。不同球队的球迷会在球场上看到不同的情况，并且他们每个人都完全确信自己
saw, in fact, is objective reality. Yeah. And sports fans often think the referees are, you know, unfair to them because they're seeing everything through their own lens. In fact, in Canada, there's one song that's banned from all the hockey arenas, and it's called Three Blind Mice, which people used to play, the home teams used to play when they didn't like a call, to imply that the three rafts were biased and blind. And so this turns out that this is like a really deeply rooted problem for people, they're
所看到的实际上就是客观现实。是的。体育迷经常认为裁判对他们不公，因为他们是通过自己的视角看待一切的。事实上，在加拿大，有一首歌被所有冰球场禁播，名叫《三只瞎老鼠》，过去人们常放这首歌，当主队不喜欢某个判罚时，主场球队就会播放它，暗示三个裁判有偏见且是瞎子。事实证明，这是一个对人们来说根深问题的问题，他们
so used to filtering it through their own lands, they get very upset at officials. The passion that we feel for our favorite sports teams can quickly lead to feelings of us versus them, whether that them we're talking about our referees or fans of our rival team. It makes sense that when we care deeply about something, we'll feel a sense of kinship with the people who share our views and a lack of connection with people who disagree with us. But it turns out, a shared passion isn't needed to trigger the psychological effects of group identity. One study published in the 1970s randomly assigned volunteers to one of two groups. The members of the first group were supposed to like the artist Paul Clay.
太习惯于通过自己的镜头来过滤信息，以至于对官员感到非常愤怒。我们对最喜欢的运动球队的热情会迅速引发我们与他们的对立感，无论我们所说的“他们”是指裁判还是我们竞争对手球队的球迷。合乎逻辑的是，当我们深深关乎某事时，我们会对那些与我们有共同观点的人产生一种亲属感，而对那些不同意我们观点的人缺乏联系。但事实证明，触发群体认同的心理效应并不需要共同的热情。20世纪70年代发表的一项研究将志愿者随机分配到两个组中。第一组的成员应该喜欢艺术家保罗·克利。
Members of the second group were supposed to lack the artist Wassily Kandinsky. This I think is one of the most important studies in the history of psychology, maybe in the history of the social sciences. So this was a study run by Henri Tashfel and his colleagues. He ran this study where he basically just randomly assigned youths to one of two groups and he did it on just trivial information. So what type of abstract art they liked and These young people didn't know these artists at all and in fact it didn't matter who they actually liked He just flipped a coin and gave them false feedback anyways The volunteers in the clay and Kandinsky camps were then told to divvy up money among people in the different groups
第二组的成员应该喜欢艺术家瓦西里·康定斯基。我认为这是心理学史上最重要的研究之一，也许也是社会科学史上最重要的研究。这是亨利·塔什费尔和他的同事们进行的一项研究。他进行了这项研究，基本上只是将年轻人随机分配到两个组中，而且他是根据极其微不足道的信息来做到的。比如他们喜欢哪种抽象艺术，这些年轻人根本不了解这些艺术家，事实上他们实际上喜欢谁并不重要，他只是抛了硬币，无论如何都给了他们虚假的反馈。克利和康定斯基阵营的志愿者随后被告知要在不同群体的成员之间分配金钱。
And what he found is that the moment that you're part of a team or part of a group, you will give more money to members of your in-group and less money to the out-group. Even if you never interact or meet those people, even if you never expect that they'll meet you, and the thing he also found is that what people really care about is maximizing the difference in money
他发现，一旦你成为一个团队或群体的一部分，你就会给内群体成员更多的钱，给外群体更少的钱。即使你从未与这些人互动或见面，即使你从不期望他们会见到你，他还发现人们真正关怀的是最大化分配给内群体和外群体的金钱差距。
they give to the in-group and out-group. So they'll actually give in-group members less if it means giving out-group members evenly in way less. What's remarkable about the study, of course, is that people are forming these loyalties to groups that they've been assigned for really no very good reason, and yet within a few minutes almost, they are behaving as if these are long-lost brothers, and they're treating them as if they're members of an in-group tribe. Yes, and this is something, you know, that it's... you might be skeptical when you hear these results, and I was too. And then I ran studies like this, you know, in Canada and the US,
所以如果这意味着给外群体成员少得多，他们实际上会给内群体成员更少。这项研究引人注目之处当然在于，人们对那些由于毫无充分理由而被指派给他们的群体形成了这种忠诚，然而在几乎几分钟内，他们的行为就好像这些是失散多年的兄弟，并把他们当成内群体部落的成员来对待。是的，这是你可以理解的……当你听到这些结果时你可能会持怀疑态度，我也是。然后我在加拿大和美国进行了这样的研究，
at many universities and online. And I've seen the same pattern over and over again. The moment that people are signed to a team or a group, even though they often can know it's a coin flip that's determining this, means that they like those people more. They wanna be friends with them. It shapes their automatic evaluations of those individuals.
在许多大学和在线上。我一次又一次地看到同样的模式。人们被分配到一个团队或群体的那一刻，尽管他们通常知道决定这一结果的是抛硬币，这意味着他们更喜欢这些人。他们想和他们成为朋友。它塑造了他们对这些个人的自动评估。
And we ran a study where NYU students thought they were interacting in economic decisions with members of NYU, which is their members of their own in group, or Columbia, which is a high status school across New York City. And what they did was they would give more money to NYU students and Columbia students.
我们进行了一项研究，纽约大学的学生认为他们正在与纽约大学的成员（也就是他们自己的内群体成员）或哥伦比亚大学（纽约市的一所高地位学校）的成员在经济决策中进行互动。他们的做法是会给纽约大学学生和哥伦比亚大学学生更多的钱。
But what was even more interesting is when they saw NYU students win money, they actually had a brain response that suggested that they were feeling as if they had won the money. And so what it suggests is what is referred to in the literature as basking and reflected glory is that when your in-group does well, it makes you feel good. You have a response in your brain as if you want or something good happened to you. And the same thing I
但更有趣的是，当他们看到纽约大学的学生赢得金钱时，他们的脑部反应实际上表明他们感觉自己赢得了这笔钱。这表明，正如文献中所指出的“借光效应”，当你的内群体表现好时，会让你感觉良好。你的大脑会产生一种仿佛你赢了或发生了好事般的反应。我认为同样的事情
think happens to sports fans. You can be sitting at home watching the TV all alone and running around and jumping and cheering as if you've accomplished something when your team wins. And this is what we found in the lab. What do you think explains this enormous gravitational force that groups exert on us, Jay? Why is it that our minds are so attuned to the needs of our groups, even when those groups are completely arbitrary? There's a couple of key factors that determine why we're so attracted to groups.
也会发生在体育迷身上。你可以独自一人坐在家里看电视，四处跑动、跳跃和欢呼，就好像你的球队获胜时你取得了什么成就一样。这就是我们在实验室中发现的。你认为是什么解释了群体对我们施加的这种巨大的引力，J？为什么我们的心灵如此高度调谐到群体的需求，即使这些群体是完全随意的？决定我们为什么如此被群体吸引有几个关键因素。
I think the deepest one is it's something in our biology. So humans evolved for almost the entirety of human history in these small tribal communities. And we're pretty flimsy creatures. We don't have sharp teeth or poison or wings to fly away for predator comms. And so we survived by cooperating in groups and coalitions within those groups. And so we survive by cooperating in groups and coalitions
我认为最深层的原因是我们的生物学特性。人类在几乎整个人类历史中都是在这些小的部落社区中进化的。我们是很脆弱的生物。我们没有尖牙、毒液或翅膀来逃避捕食者的威胁。因此，我们通过在这些群体内部进行合作来生存。因此，我们通过在这些群体内部进行合作
within those groups. And so we have those same tendencies. And then what you have in a modern environment that matters is that groups feel our need to belong. You know, they help us gain status if we're part of a successful group. And they also give us a sense of distinctiveness. If our group is different from others, it tells us a little bit in the world about who
来生存。所以我们拥有这些相同的倾向。然后在现代环境中重要的是，群体满足了我们的归属需求。你知道，如果我们是成功群体的一部分，它们会帮我们获得地位。它们还给我们一种独特性。如果我们的群体与众不同，它会在世界上向我们透露一点关于我们是谁的信息。
we are. Groups offer us a sense of belonging and they can bring out the best in us. But the flip side of most in groups, there's an out group. When we come back, how our group identity identities divide us and what we can do to harness the power of groups to build a better world. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We've seen how groups can pull us together, give us shared cultural touch points and become
群体为我们提供归属感，它们能激发我们最好的一面。但大多数内群体的另一面是外群体。当我们回来时，我们将探讨我们的群体认同如何分裂我们，以及我们能做些什么来利用群体的力量建设一个更好的世界。您正在收听的是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维达姆塔姆。这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维达姆塔姆。我们已经看到群体如何将我们凝聚在一起、赋予我们共同的文化触点，并成为
an enduring source of resilience and comfort. In our evolutionary past, our group identities were an important source of protection. You will think that a force this powerful would also have downsides. Throughout human history, we've seen numerous examples of how group loyalty is can spill over into tribalism and xenophobia and lead to war and genocide. In their new book The Power of Us, the psychologist J. Van Bevel and Dominic Packer explore how group identities pull us together and how they tear us apart.
持久的韧性和慰藉之源。在我们的演化过去中，群体认同是重要的保护源泉。你会认为如此强大的力量也会有负面影响。纵观人类历史，我们看到了无数关于群体忠诚如何演变为部落主义和仇外心理并导致战争与种族的灭绝的例子。在他们的新书《我们之力量》（The Power of Us）中，心理学家J·范贝维尔和多米尼克·帕克探讨了群体认同如何将我们凝聚在一起以及它们如何将我们分裂。
They also look at how we can apply what we have learned about the science of group identity to build a better world. J-you tell a remarkable story of two brothers in southern Germany. They were cobblers and together ran the Dastler brothers shoe factory around the time of the second world war. The brothers had a falling out. What happened next? So these brothers it was World War II, 1943 and the one brother Addy, he and his wife climbed into the same shelter as his brother Rudolph's family and Addy said according to legend, the dirty bastards are back again.
他们还研究了我们如何将关于群体认同科学的认知应用于建设一个更好的世界。J，你讲述了一个关于德国南部两兄弟的非凡故事。他们是鞋匠，在第二次世界大战前后共同经营达斯勒兄弟鞋厂。兄弟俩闹翻了。接下来发生了什么？所以这两兄弟在二战期间的1943年，其中一个兄弟阿迪，他和他的妻子爬进了和他兄弟鲁道夫的家人同一个防空洞，据传说阿迪说：“那些肮脏的混蛋又回来了。”
And we don't know if Addy was referring to the allied warplanes who were coming to bomb them. But Rudy apparently interpreted this as an insult intended for himself and his family. And so it triggered this decades-long feud between these two brothers. They ended up breaking up their company and creating two shoe companies in the same town and
我们不知道阿迪是否指的是前来轰炸他们的盟军战机。但鲁迪显然将此解释为针对他和他的家人的侮辱。因此这引发了这两兄弟之间长达数十年的宿怨。他们最终解散了公司，在同一个小镇上创建了两家鞋厂，并且
That might have been the end of it right, but what happened is it infected the psychology of all the town's people and so people on one side of the river of the town Identified with Adi and the other side identified with the shoe company one by Rudy and it became known as the town of bent necks because people would walk around town looking down at the ground to see what shoes people were wearing. And if you were wearing a shoes, the shoes from the other company, you went date them, you wouldn't be able to go in those stores, marriage was discouraged with people with the wrong shoes. In fact, this feud went right to the grave, so these two brothers are literally buried at opposite ends of the town cemetery. And this might seem like this is a small story. It's just a little town in Germany. But these companies, the two shoe companies that were launched by them are now known as Adidas,
这本可以就此结束对吧，但发生的事情是它感染了全镇居民的心理，所以镇上河的一边的人认同阿迪，另一边的人认同鲁迪拥有的鞋厂，它被称为“歪脖子镇”，因为人们会在镇上四处走动时低头看着地面，看看别人穿的是什么鞋。如果你穿着一双鞋，来自另一家公司的鞋，你不会和他们约会，你不能进入那些商店，与穿错鞋的人结婚是不被鼓励的。事实上，这场宿怨一直延续到坟墓里，所以这两兄弟实际上被埋葬在镇墓地的两端。这看起来可能是一个小故事。这只是德国的一个小镇。但这些公司，由他们创立的两家鞋厂现在被称为阿迪达斯（Adidas），
which was founded by Addy and Puma, which was founded by Rudy. These are two of the biggest companies in the world. And this feud affected the psychology of everybody because these shoes became a signal about group membership and led to discrimination. So, you know, when I look out at the United States or other countries, I feel there are endless examples of how our group loyalties divide us. The conflict between the Dazzler brothers, you know, to me it seems absurd. You know, they're both German,
由阿迪创立，以及彪马（Puma），由鲁迪创立。这是世界上两家最大的公司。这场宿怨影响了每个人的心理，因为这些鞋子成为了群体成员身份的信号并导致了歧视。所以，你知道，当我审视美国或其他国家时，我觉得有无穷无尽的例子表明我们的群体忠诚如何分裂了我们。达斯勒兄弟之间的冲突，你知道，在我看来似乎很荒谬。你知道，他们都是德国人，
they're both cobblers, they both make sports shoes for heaven's sake. Surely they have so much in common. But of course, when we find ourselves in the grip of deep divisions, they don't seem absurd. What explains this gap? The Dazzler Brothers demonstrates something really deep about human nature.
他们都是鞋匠，看在上帝的份上，他们都制造运动鞋。他们肯定有很多共同点。但当然，当我们发现自己陷入深深的分裂中时，它们看起来并不荒谬。是什么解释了这种差距？达斯勒兄弟展示了关于人性的非常深层的东西。
How easily we form groups and coalitions. And this has been observed in every culture on Earth that's ever been studied. And to these people in this town, this doesn't seem absurd. This seems deeply important and central to their life and who they are. And I think that's the thing psychologically is whatever conflicts are driving your own life.
我们形成群体和联盟是多么容易。这在有史以来研究过的每一个人类文化中都被观察到。对于这个小镇上的这些人来说，这并不显得荒谬。这似乎极其重要，对他们的生活和他们是谁至关重要。我认为在心理学上就是这样，无论是什么冲突在驱动你自己的生活。
Seem real. And the conflicts of other people halfway around the world might seem absurd. But it's very much the same psychology that seems to be at play in all of these types of situations. So many Americans increasingly believe they don't just disagree with people on the other side, but that people on the other side are inherently evil
看起来都是真实的。而在世界另一半的其他人的冲突可能看起来很荒谬。但在所有这些类型的情况中，起作用的心理机制在很大程度上是相同的。越来越多的美国人相信，他们不仅仅是与另一方的人意见不合，而是另一方的人本质上是邪恶的
or untrustworthy. As a social scientist who studies group identity, where are we on the spectrum between healthy disagreement and civil war? What I've noticed is there's an increasing trend towards polarization that's linked to out-group hate more than in-group love. And this is where politics in the US and many places around the world looks much more like sectarianism because it's connected to our morality.
或不可信的。作为一名研究群体认同的社会科学家，我们在健康的分歧和内战之间的光谱上处于什么位置？我注意到的是，存在一种日益严重的极化趋势，这与外群体仇恨的联系多于内群体热爱。这就是为什么美国和世界许多地方的政治看起来更像是宗派主义，因为它与我们的道德相连。
And what happens then is people on the in-group are good, but the out-group really is evil. And you'll do anything you can to stop them. You'll even support an in-group member or vote for a leader who you don't like or don't respect or don't trust. Simply because you can't let this evil out-group take control. And so this is now a driving factor behind many people in their decisions to vote, volunteer, donate money. You've conducted studies into how these group-level disagreements spill over into our personal
然后发生的情况是，内群体的人是好的，但外群体确实是邪恶的。你会尽一切努力阻止他们。你甚至会支持一个你不喜欢、不尊重或不信任的内群体成员或投票给一个领导者。仅仅因为你不能让这个邪恶的外群体接管控制权。因此，这现在成为许多人在投票、做志愿者、捐款决策背后的驱动因素。你进行了关于这些群体层面的分歧如何蔓延到我们个人
lives. How do these political loyalties divide families at holiday gatherings, like Thanksgiving? Research suggests that our Thanksgiving dinners are getting shorter. By roughly half an hour over time, if you're interacting with family members in a place where there's going to be disagreement politically, it becomes intolerable and people just, you know, don't stick around for dessert, basically. It's affected dating. So I ran a study with radio station in New York City at Trump's inauguration, and we found
生活中的研究。这些政治忠诚如何在感恩节等节日聚会上分裂家庭？研究表明，我们的感恩节晚餐正在缩短。随着时间的推移，如果你与家庭成员在政治上会有分歧的地方互动，它就会变得令人无法忍受，人们基本上就，你知道的，不会留下来吃甜点。它影响了约会。所以我与纽约大学的一家广播电台在特朗普就职典礼期间进行了一项研究，我们发现
the biggest form of discrimination we observed is simply that people refuse to date somebody who voted for the other party. And so now there's in fact dating websites dedicated specifically to your political preferences. Are you serious? There's blue Tinder and red Tinder now? I don't know if it's called that.
我们观察到的最大形式的歧视仅仅是人们拒绝与投票给另一个党派的人约会。所以现在实际上有专门针对你的政治偏好的约会网站。你是认真的？现在有蓝色Tinder和红色Tinder了吗？我不知道它是不是叫那个。
There's one that's like a, if you're for Trump fans only and stuff like this. Yeah So we we talked to you earlier about how our group loyalties and identity shape are very perceptions of reality I want to talk about this idea and the context of group conflicts You've conducted some interesting studies looking at Yankees fans What do you find in terms of their perceptions when it comes to their enemies, the Red Sox? Yeah, so one of the greatest sports rivalries in the country is between the New York Yankees and the Boston Red Sox. And we've been able to run some studies up at Yankees Stadium with Red Sox and Yankees fans. And what we found is that Yankees fans had distorted judgments of how close Fenway Park in Boston was.
有一个网站类似于，如果你只支持特朗普的粉丝等等。是的，所以我们之前向你们谈过我们的群体忠诚和身份如何塑造我们对现实的感知。我想在群体冲突的背景下谈谈这个想法。你进行了一些有趣的关于扬基队球迷的研究？当涉及到他们的敌人红袜队时，你在他们的感知方面发现了什么？是的，国内最伟大的体育宿怨之一就是在纽约扬基队和波士顿红袜队之间。我们已经在扬基体育场与红袜队和扬基队的球迷开展了一些研究。我们发现扬基队的球迷对波士顿的芬威球场有多近有着扭曲的判断。
So we gave them a map and asked them to draw where they thought Boston was. And they thought it was much closer to New York than it actually was. If you asked non-Fans, they were pretty accurate in estimating how far away Fenway Park was. But they're not threatened by this group in the same way that Yankees fans are.
所以我们给了他们一张地图，让他们画出他们认为波士顿在哪里的位置。他们认为它比实际距离纽约近得多。如果你问非球迷，他们在估计芬威球场有多远时相当准确。但他们没有受到这个群体的威胁，不像扬基球迷那样。
And so they're not distorting their perceptions in the same way the Yankees fans are and so they're not distorting their perceptions in the same way And so this is something that is adaptive to people is if there's a threat in the environment You got to get ready to act and seeing it as closer can sometimes trigger that reaction But we see it with groups as well. I understand this also been similar work finding that people who perceive immigrants to be a greater threat Can sometimes perceive them to be physically closer or perceive their home countries to be physically closer than they actually are. We've run a number of studies in New York and around the rest of the country.
所以他们没有像扬基球迷那样扭曲他们的感知，所以他们没有以同样的方式扭曲他们的感知。因此，这是对人们具有适应性的一点，如果环境中存在威胁，你必须准备好采取行动，认为它更近有时可以触发这种反应。但我们在群体中也看到了这一点。据我所知，也有类似的研究发现，那些认为移民构成更大威胁的人有时会认为他们在物理上更近，或者认为他们的祖国比实际距离更近。我们在纽约和全国其他地方进行了一系列研究。
And what we find is that people who are threatened by illegal immigration from Mexico see Mexico City as much closer to the border than it is. But also how many people they think are coming over the border. They tend to overestimate the size of the group. So the idea that group identity is like a lens through which we see the world. I think this might explain why some things that we feel should provide objective answers to complex social problems sometimes fail to do so.
我们发现，受到来自墨西哥的非法移民威胁的人认为墨西哥城比实际距离边境要近得多。不仅如此，他们还认为有多少人越过边境。他们往往高估了该群体的大小。因此，群体认同就像是一副我们用来观察世界的镜头的观点。我认为这可以解释为什么有些我们觉得应该为复杂社会问题提供客观答案的事情有时未能做到这一点。
There's been controversy in recent years about police shootings of civilians and both protesters and police have assumed that the body cameras being worn by police officers, these can provide an objective answer as to who's in the right. What are these protesters and the police officials getting wrong, Jay? Well, the body cams have operated on the assumption that if we just captured all in the cameras, that it's going to dramatically reduce police violence because it's going to keep people honest. And the problem with that is that people, when they look at these videos in a court, the jury, for example, is biased in how they interpret them. So there is research from NYU showing that if you identify with the police and you watch
近年来关于警察枪击平民的事件一直存在争议，抗议者和警察都认为警察佩戴的执法记录仪可以提供关于谁对谁错的客观答案。这些抗议者和警察官员搞错了什么，J？嗯，执法记录仪的运作假设是，如果我们把所有内容都拍在摄像机上，它将显著减少警察暴力，因为它会让人们保持诚实。而这其中存在的问题是，当人们在法庭上观看这些录像时，例如陪审团，他们在解释这些录像时是有偏见的。纽约大学的研究表明，如果你认同警察并且你观看
one of these videos of a conflict between a police officer and the suspect, you see the suspect at fault and you're looking more at the suspect and therefore you're getting the information they're doing something wrong. If you actually don't identify at the police, you are looking at the police officer to see what they're doing wrong and coming to a very different conclusion. So simply having the video is not going to be enough to solve these problems and necessarily reduce conflict with the place. I want to ask you what all this means for the COVID-19 pandemic. At the time, you and I are having this conversation, Jay, a significant number of Americans are resistant to getting vaccinated against COVID-19. And the data seems to suggest that the death rates and
其中一个警察和嫌疑人冲突的视频，你会看到嫌疑人有过错，你会更多地看着嫌疑人，因此你获得的信息是他们在做错事。如果你实际上不认同警察，你会看着警察看他们在做什么错事，并得出非常不同的结论。因此，仅仅拥有视频是不够的来解决这些问题并必然减少与警察的冲突。我想问你，所有这一切对2019冠状病毒病大流行意味着什么。在你我进行这次对话的时候，J，相当一部分美国人对接种新冠疫苗心存抵触。数据似乎表明，死亡率和
infection rates are rising primarily among the unvaccinated. And I think the response of many public health officials is to say, you know, let's present people with the data, but of course, that doesn't seem to change people's mind. And as I'm hearing what you are saying about group identities and the ways in which conversations about the pandemic have become politicized, I think I'm starting to see why it is that rational fact-based approach often is ineffective. If there was ever a moment where we would want to test a hypothesis
感染率主要在未接种疫苗的人群中上升。我认为许多公共卫生官员的反应是说，你知道，让我们向人们展示数据，但当然，这似乎并没有改变人们的想法。当我听到你所说的关于群体认同以及有关大流行的对话如何被政治化的言论时，我想我开始明白为什么理性的、基于事实的方法往往是无效的。如果曾经有过一个我们想要检验假设的时刻
about whether facts and risks actually make people rational, we have tested it during the pandemic. And what we've seen since the very beginning, since January of 2020 in the US, is that Republicans have seen the pandemic unfolding very differently than Democrats. And the leaders of the Republicans, this is Donald Trump, have downplayed it. And this affected people's judgments of risk. It affected willingness to engage in spatial and social distancing.
关于事实和风险是否真的能让人变得理性，我们在大流行期间进行了测试。从一开始，即2020年1月在美国，我们看到的情况是，共和党人对疫情演变的看法与民主党人截然不同。共和党领导人，也就是唐纳德·特朗普，淡化了疫情的影响。这影响了人们对风险的判断。它影响了人们进行空间和社交距离保持的意愿。
And we've studied that in my own lab and found that, over time, the partisan gap between Democrats and Republicans in their willingness to engage in distancing actually increased as the pandemic spread. You might expect the opposite, which is that as people learn more about the risks, as people dying, getting the hospital in your local state or city, you would actually follow the guidelines more. You wouldn't be guided by a partis If anything, we found the exact opposite. And now you're seeing that with vaccines. The single biggest predictor of vaccine hesitancy continues to be identification with the Republican party. 32% of Republicans don't plan to get the vaccine. We're only 3% of Democrats don't plan to.
我们在我自己的实验室里对此进行了研究，发现随着时间的推移，民主党人和共和党人在保持社交距离意愿上的党派鸿沟随着疫情的蔓延实际上在拉大。你可能会预料到相反的结果，即随着人们对风险了解的加深，随着人们在你的本地州或城市死去、住进医院，你实际上会更多地遵循指南。你不会受党派引导。然而恰恰相反，我们发现的结果完全相反。现在你从疫苗身上看到了这一点。疫苗犹豫不决的最单一最大预测因素依然是对共和党身份的认同。32%的共和党人不打算接种疫苗。而只有3%的民主党人不打算接种。
So that's 10 times as many people are vaccine hesitants on that side of the political aisle. I mean, I mean, the other way to sort of describe what you just said is that our commitment to our groups and our group identities in some ways can be stronger than our commitments to our own safety. Yeah, group identities don't seem that important when you're talking about, you know, a baseball game, but they matter a great deal in a pandemic. And if they are stronger than our commitment to reality and preserving the safety of not only ourselves, but our family, our friends, our co-workers,
因此，在政治天平的另一端，犹豫不决接种疫苗的人数是另一边的10倍。我的意思是，换一种方式来形容你刚才所说的话，那就是我们对我们的群体和群体身份的承诺在某些方面可以强于我们对自己安全的承诺。是的，当你谈论棒球比赛时，群体身份似乎并没有那么重要，但在大流行中它们却至关重要。如果它们强于我们对现实以及维护不仅是我们自己，还有我们的家人、朋友、同事的安全的承诺，
that tells you precisely how powerful these things are. And if you're willing to continue to tune into TV stations or social media that's affirming your identity, it can lead you to have a very bad misunderstanding of the risks that are presented to you in the world around. JNS colleagues have looked at how social media in particular exacerbates tribal loyalties and group divisions. We explored some of this research in an earlier episode. It was titled Screaming Into the Void.
这就确切地告诉你这些东西有多强大。如果你愿意继续收听那些肯定你身份的电视频道或社交媒体，它会导致你对周围世界呈现给你的风险产生非常严重的误解。JNS的同事实地考察了社交媒体尤其是如何加剧部落忠诚和群体分裂的。我们在之前的一集节目中探讨了部分这项研究。它的节目名称是《向虚空尖叫》。
The important thing to understand about social media is that nearly four billion people are on social media now. And the average social media user scrolls through 300 feet of news feed a day. So that means if you have a six inch iPhone or Android, that means you're scrolling down 600 times. It's the height of the statue you're Wow. That's how much you're reading each day. And so you're not reading things very deeply. You're just kind of scrolling through and seeing what catches your attention. That's why they call it attention economy. We've run a number of studies with hundreds of thousands of people and we found that the language
关于社交媒体，需要理解的重要一点是，现在近有四十亿人在使用社交媒体。平均每个社交媒体用户每天滚动浏览300英尺（约91米）的信息流。这意味着如果你有一个6英寸的iPhone或安卓手机，那就意味着你向下滚动了600次。这相当于雕像的高度。哇。这就是你每天阅读的内容量。因此，你并没有非常深入地阅读。你只是在滚动浏览，看看什么能吸引你的注意力。这就是为什么他们称之为注意力经济。我们对几十万人进行了多项研究，我们发现，人们使用的语言
people are using seems to break through in this attention economy. So when people use powerful moral emotional language around political topics, it seems to break through in this attention economy. So when people use powerful moral, emotional language around political topics, it seems to go more viral. People are 15 to 20% more likely to share it. But what happens is who's sharing it? It's people who are part of your own political in-group. It doesn't cross over to the other side
似乎在这个注意力经济中脱颖而出。因此，当人们在政治话题周围使用强烈的道德情感语言时，它似乎在这个注意力经济中脱颖而出。当人们在政治话题周围使用强烈的道德、情感语言时，它似乎传播得更广。人们转发它的可能性要高出15%到20%。但问题是，是谁在转发？是那些属于你自己的政治内群体的人。它不会跨越到另一边
when you use that language. And we have a new study out where we found that the biggest single predictor of making something go viral is dunking on the out group, saying something negative about the other side. And that's 67% more likely to get shared. And so people learn this by getting reinforced. And they realize this is the language that wins on social media. You've also conducted a study looking at the effectiveness of fact checking partisan beliefs. What do you find, Jay?
当你使用那种语言时。我们有一项新的研究表明，让某事病毒式传播的最单一最大预测因素是打压外群体，说一些关于另一方的负面言论。这被转发的可能性要高出67%。因此，人们通过得到强化来学会这一点。他们意识到这是在社交媒体上取胜的语言。你还进行了一项研究，考察了对党派信仰进行事实核查的有效性。你发现了什么，杰伊？
Yeah, we've been trying to study what works in terms of fact checking. There is some evidence that if you give people nudges to focus on accuracy, they'll kind of pause and reflect and be more accurate and be less likely to believe or share misinformation. We have new data suggesting that that doesn't really work for people at the political extremes. Their identity is overpowering these nudges for accuracy. So we're going to have to think about addressing those people in different ways if we're going to want
是的，我们一直在努力研究事实核查在什么情况下有效。有一些证据表明，如果你给人们一些提示让他们关注准确性，他们就会停下来反思，从而变得更准确，并且不太可能相信或分享错误信息。我们的新数据表明，这对处于政治极端的人来说并没有真正作用。他们的身份盖过了这些对准确性的提示。因此，如果我们想要减少错误信息，
to reduce misinformation. Across so many dimensions of our lives, our group identity shape, our perceptions, our choices, and our behavior. They can cause us to act with cruelty and aggression. They can also prompt us to show compassion and generosity to what others. When we come back, how we can harness and redirect the power of groups to improve our health, our communities, and the well-being of the planet. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
我们将不得不考虑用不同的方式来应对这些人。在我们生活的诸多维度中，我们的群体身份塑造了我们的认知、选择和行为。它们可能导致我们采取残酷和具有攻击性的行动。它们也可以促使我们对他人表现出同情和慷慨。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何利用和重塑群体的力量，来改善我们的健康、社区以及地球的福祉。您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Our social worlds shape what we see. They offer us comfort in the face of threat. They give us a sense of camaraderie. They're also the prism through which we see and understand the world. In their book, The Power of Us, the psychologist Javan Bavill and Dominic Packer explore how we can harness our group identities
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们的社交世界塑造了我们的所见。在面对威胁时，它们为我们提供安慰。它们给我们一种同甘共苦的战友情谊。它们也是我们看清和理解世界的棱镜。心理学家杰凡·巴维尔（Javan Bavill）和多米尼克·帕克（Dominic Packer）在他们的书《我们的力量》（The Power of Us）中探讨了我们如何利用群体身份
to solve important challenges in our lives. Jay, one of the themes that has surfaced repeatedly in this conversation is that our group identities change the way we see the world. Now, most of the time, the forces that create group identities are random or accidental, but understanding how group identities are created can give us clues to how to reinvent those identities to change the outcomes we'd like to see in the world. I'd like to start with a personal story. You were in grad school, you were assigned an office mate, Dominic Packer, he would of
来解决我们生活中的重要挑战。杰伊，这次对话中反复出现的一个主题是，我们的群体身份改变了我们看待世界的方式。现在，大多数时候，产生群体身份的力量是随机或偶然的，但了解群体身份是如何产生的，可以为我们如何重塑这些身份以改变我们希望在世界上看到的结果提供线索。我想从一个个人故事开始。你当时在读研究生，被分到一个办公室室友，多米尼克·帕克（Dominic Packer），他后来
course go on to become your collaborator and your co-author on this book, but you had something of a rocky start when you first met, and it had to do with some smelly gym clothes that you brought to your shared office. And I was a big hockey player, and I picked a desk in the sub-basement of our building in the same room as Dominic, who had been there for a year. And I had such a small apartment that I had no room for my hockey equipment.
当然成了你的合作者和这本书的合著者，但你们刚见面时的开局有点坎坷，这与你带到你们共用办公室的一些有异味的健身衣服有关。我曾经是个出色的曲棍球运动员，我在我们大楼的地下一层选了一张桌子，和多米尼克在同一个房间里，他在那里已经呆了一年了。我的公寓太小了，根本没有地方放我的曲棍球装备。
So I brought it in and I said, I'm just gonna store this here. And this basically chilled our relationship. For the next several months, Dominic barely turned around to talk to me. He was pretty burned about the idea of me storing my stinky hockey equipment in our shared office. So tell me the story of how the bond between the two of you
所以我把它带了进来，我说，我只想把它存放在这里。这基本上冷却了我们的关系。在接下来的几个月里，多米尼克几乎不转过身来跟我说话。对于我把臭气熏天的曲棍球装备存在我们共用的办公室里这个想法，他感到非常恼火。那么，请告诉我你们两人的纽带是如何
got established. I understand a cube of cheese was involved. Yeah, so one of the rituals of being a graduate student at most universities is they bring in guest speakers. As a grad student, you're at the bottom of the pecking order, but you get to meet the speakers, take them for lunch, and then they often have a nice wine and cheese reception. And so at the wine and cheese reception, I was a poor student, I was eating as much cheese as I could, drinking as much free beer as I could.
建立起来的。我听说其中牵涉到了一块奶酪。是的，所以作为大多数大学的研究生，有一个传统就是邀请特邀演讲嘉宾。作为研究生，你处于食物链的底端，但你可以见到演讲者，带他们去吃午餐，然后他们通常会有一个不错的葡萄酒和奶酪招待会。在那个葡萄酒和奶酪招待会上，我是一个穷学生，我尽可能多地吃奶酪，尽可能多地喝免费啤酒。
And I wasn't paying attention to what I was eating. And I dropped this cheese cube. It was about the size of a dice into my throat. And it got plugged in my throat. And I started choking. And I tried to rinse it down with some beer, but that just made the situation worse. At that point, I had zero oxygen going to my brain. And I thought back to the times I used to work in the oil field of Alberta, I had to watch
我没有注意自己在吃什么。我把这块大约骰子大小的奶酪块掉进了喉咙里。它卡在了我的喉咙里。我开始窒息。我试图用一些啤酒把它冲下去，但这只会让情况变得更糟。那时，我的大脑完全没有氧气了。我想起了我在艾伯塔省油田工作时的情景，我不得不观看
all these safety videos. And the first thing I learned was that if you're choking, most people can save you as long you don't leave the room. But it's so embarrassing to choke that most people who die do so because they just want to be alone and not have other people see them. So I went to the bartender and I couldn't speak, but I kind of like made the universal choking signature. And then I twisted into him with my back, but he didn't really know what was going on
所有这些安全视频。我学到的第一件事是，如果你窒息了，只要你不出房间，大多数人都能救你。但是窒息是如此尴尬，以至于大多数死者之所以死，是因为他们只想独自一人，不让别人看到他们。所以我走到酒保面前，我说不出话来，但我有点像做出了通用的窒息手势。然后我用后背转向他，但他真的不知道发生了什么，
and didn't help me that much. So I grabbed Omnick's hand and pulled him into the men's room and he didn't know what was going on either at that point. But I communicated to him that I need him to do the Heimlich on me or I would die. And he looked like white like he had seen a ghost. But eventually he got in the position I kind of like sort of moving his hands
也没有帮我太多忙。所以我抓住奥姆尼克（Omnick）的手把他拉进男洗手间，当时他也不知道发生了什么。但我向他传达了我需要他对我和海姆立克急救法（Heimlich），否则我就会死。他看起来像见到鬼一样脸色苍白。但最终他摆好姿势，我有点像是在移动他的双手
towards my diaphragm and he gave me the Heimlich, it came out. And I remember at the end of this, there was professors coming in to use the washroom and out and they're looking at us like what are you guys doing in here? But it bonded us together. This weird near death experience,
朝向我的横膈膜，他对我实施了海姆立克急救法，东西出来了。我记得在这结束时，有教授走进来用洗手间，他们看着我们，好像在说你们俩在这里面干什么？但这把我们紧紧地联系在了一起。这种诡异的濒死体验，
almost me almost dying at the wine and cheese and him having to save my life created a bridge. us together. This weird, near-death experience, almost me almost dying at the line in cheese, and him having to save my life created a bridge, and from that point on, we became close friends, and then we became collaborators, and now we're still working together. It's a remarkable story, and I'm glad that both you and he had the presence of mine to sort of solve the problem. But talk about this idea a little more, Jay. Stressful situations and dramatic situations have a capacity to bond people together.
几乎让我在葡萄酒和奶酪招待会上死去，而他不得不救我的命，这架起了一座桥梁。把我们联系在一起。这种诡异的濒死体验，几乎让我在葡萄酒和奶酪招待会上死去，而他不得不救我的命，这架起了一座桥梁，从那一刻起，我们成了密友，然后我们成了合作者，现在我们还在合作。这是一个非凡的故事，我很高兴你和他都有临场应变能力来解决这个问题。但是杰伊，再多谈谈这个想法。压力情境和戏剧性情境有能力将人们凝聚在一起。
I'm reminded of those studies involving dating couples. And when the couples are having a date on a rickety bridge where they feel like their lives might be in danger, they feel more drawn to one another. They feel like they have a bigger bond than if they're having a very safe date. And there have been stories about airplane hijackings where passengers feel like they're thrown in together in the same kind of situations.
这让我想起了那些涉及约会情侣的研究。当情侣在一座摇摇欲坠、感觉生命可能处于危险之中的桥上约定时，他们会觉得彼此更有吸引力。与在一个非常安全的约会中相比，他们觉得彼此之间的纽带更深。还有一些关于飞机劫持的故事，乘客们觉得他们被抛入了同一种处境中。
This cauldron, if you will, and out of that cauldron comes sort of this very intense bond. One of the most interesting studies I've ever read was written by a woman in the 70s who was part of a hijacking by a terrorist group. She survived the ordeal and wrote this paper about what it was like psychologically among the passengers as they were held hostage for several days in this hijacked plane in the middle of the desert and What we learned by reading this and going through back to the story was that when you're all in this crisis together It creates a sense of shared purpose and so what happened over the course of these days was it's first started creating like subgroups of people depending on what passport They had and what their nationality was and eventually they all started to bond and you know rationed food and
这个大熔炉，如果你愿意这么说的话，而从这个大熔炉中诞生了这种非常强烈的纽带。我读过的最有趣的研究之一是一位女士在70年代写的，她是一场由恐怖组织发起的劫机事件的亲历者。她在大难不死后写了这篇论文，讲述了当他们在沙漠中央被劫持的飞机上作为人质被扣留好几天时，乘客之间的心理状态是怎样的。我们通过阅读这篇文章并回顾这个故事了解到，当你一起处于这场危机中时，它会产生一种共同的目标感。因此，在这些天里发生的事情是，它首先开始根据他们拿的是什么护照、属于什么国籍来创建不同的人群子集，最终他们都开始建立联系，你知道的，定量配给食物，
Worked together to support one another and people who had small children and so it became a shared identity as people going through this crisis together. And this is often what crises can do if we handle them well, that it allows humans to form a sense of solidarity with complete strangers. I want to look at one last example of how a behavior can be modified when a group identities change. When Muhammad Salah or Mosulah as he is known, joined the Liverpool Football Club in Britain. He often celebrated goals by dropping to the pitch and touching his forehead to the grass.
齐心协力互相支持，那些有小孩的人也是如此，因此，当人们一起经历这场危机时，它变成了一种共同的身份。如果我们处理得当，危机往往能做到这一点，它能让Humans（人类）对素不相识的人产生一种声气相求的团结感。我想看看行为如何在群体身份改变时被修改的最后一个例子。当穆罕默德·萨拉赫（Mohamed Salah），也就是人们熟知的莫·萨拉（Mo Salah），加入英国的利物浦足球俱乐部时，他经常通过倒向球场并将额头触碰草皮来庆祝进球。
Mosulim and this was his way of giving thanks. Now Liverpool fans have the same anti-Muslim bias as seen in many western countries, but here is how they reacted as more scored goals. And then I'll be Muslim, sir. It's a golden of for you. It's golden of for me. And say it in a mosque, that's where I want to be. I'll start. La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la. Jay, what are you here when you hear these fans singing about wanting to become Muslims themselves? This is a really powerful demonstration of the way that we rethink our identities when
莫斯林（Mosulim，注：原文口误或空耳），这是他表达感恩的方式。现在利物浦球迷和许多西方国家一样，有着同样的抗穆斯林偏见，但随着莫进球，他们的反应是这样的。然后我会成为穆斯林，先生。这是为你的一粒金球。这是为我的一粒金球。在清真寺里说出来，那是我想要去的地方。我要开始了。啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦。杰伊，当你听到这些球迷歌唱他们自己想要成为穆斯林时，你听到了什么？这有力地证明了当我们
someone is part of us. And so even though there's a lot of anti-Muslim attitudes in the UK, having a representative of this religious group on your team, and especially real superstar, made them feel a connection to him. And in this case, it sounds like even their religion. And so there was this great study by Salma Musa and her colleagues, and
某人成为我们的一部分时，我们重新审视自己身份的方式。因此，尽管英国存在很多反穆斯林情绪，但在你的团队中拥有这个宗教群体的代表，尤其是真正的超级巨星，让他们感到了与他的联系。在这个例子中，听起来甚至包括了他们的宗教。因此，萨尔玛·穆萨（Salma Musa）和她的同事做了一项很棒的研究，并且
they found that among these Liverpool fans, they observed that hate crimes in that area dropped by 16 percent, and that even public expressions on Twitter, so anti-Muslim tweets, dropped by nearly half among Liverpool fans compared to fans from other groups. And so this was a really powerful way of changing the norms of a group to be more inclusive and tolerant and embracing of people who are normally considered outsiders. Now, of course, Liverpool didn't recruit Moasala because he was a Muslim. They were doing it because he's a great athlete who was going to score a lot of goals for them. But most of fact, on the attitudes of Liverpool fans raises the question of whether we can deliberately create group
他们发现在这些利物浦球迷中，他们观察到该地区的仇恨犯罪下降了16%，与来自其他群体的球迷相比，利物浦球迷在推特上的公开表达，即反穆斯林推文，甚至下降了近一半。因此，这是一种强有力的方式，可以改变群体的规范，使其更具包容性、宽容性，并接纳那些通常被认为是局外人的人。当然，利物浦招募莫·萨拉赫并不是因为他是穆斯林。他们这样做是因为他是一名伟大的运动员，将为他们攻入很多进球。但莫对利物浦球迷态度的实际影响引发了一个问题：我们是否可以刻意制造群体身份来凌驾于偏见和部落主义之上。你刚才引用了研究员萨尔玛·穆萨（Salma Musa），据我了解，她通过让基督徒和穆斯林在伊拉克北部的同一支足球队踢球来测试这个想法。你能告诉我关于“足球疗法”这个想法吗？
identities that override prejudice and tribalism. You just cited the researcher, Salma Musa, who's tested this idea, I understand, by trying to get Christians and Muslims to play on the same soccer teams in Northern Iraq. Can you tell me about this idea of the soccer cure? Yeah, she did this amazing study, really mind-blowing in how she pulled it off. She did this study in Northern Iraq and it was at a period of time where ISIS
是的，她做了这项令人惊叹的研究，她在如何完成这项研究方面简直令人叫绝。她在伊拉克北部做了这项研究，当时正值ISIS
had caused chaos. People had reinforced to flee their homes and live in refugee camps and eventually they were liberated in 2016. And she went into these neighborhoods and created a summer soccer league. And she got a sample of Muslims and Christians, and she had them play on these summer soccer teams.
造成混乱的时期。人们被迫逃离家园，住在难民营中，最终在2016年他们获得了解放。她进入这些社区，建立了一个夏季足球联赛。她找了一组穆斯林和基督徒的样本，让他们在这些夏季足球队中踢球。
And they generated a sense of connection with people from these other religions who were on their teams, even though they didn't want to play with people from other religions, having them on their team increased their connection with them and she measured all of these positive outcomes as a consequence of this.
他们与团队中来自这些其他宗教的人产生了联系感，尽管他们起初不想和来自其他宗教的人踢球，但让他们加入自己的团队增加了他们之间的联系，作为结果，她衡量了所有这些积极的结果。
And it's hard to imagine a more divisive situation to walk into other than religious differences after a period of religious terrorism and people being forced to go to refugee camps. But what this showed is that being part of the same team working towards a common shared goal, and especially I think what she found was also that teams that won, what were successful at doing this, had even tighter bonds. That shows how sports and just any type of connection we can build with people working
很难想象在经历了一段宗教恐怖主义和人们被迫前往难民营的时期之后，除了宗教分歧之外，还有什么情况比这更具分裂性。但这就表明，作为同一个团队的一部分，朝着一个共同的共同目标努力，特别是我想她还发现，获胜的、在这方面取得成功的团队，拥有更紧密的联系。这表明体育以及我们可以与为了共同目标而努力的人建立的任何类型的联系，都可以弥合我们可能认为完全无法弥合的鸿沟。现在，我想你可以说，人们为足球明星欢呼，或者人们为团队中的同伴欢呼，这是群体身份的一种廉价形式。它不如宗教或存在时间更久远的东西那样真实。但在某种程度上，我们所有的群体忠诚可能都是由类似的力量塑造的，即随着时间推移成为我们生活支柱的小小的偶然事件。是的。当我们想到身份时，最好还是从小处着手，寻找你和某人之间的任何共同点，然后你需要在此基础上进行建设，让他们为更大的事情合作，也许以一种不有害或不危险的方式与其他群体竞争，或者至少拥有共同的目标感。
towards common purpose, can bridge gaps that we might have thought were completely unbridgeable. Now, I suppose you could say that people cheering a soccer star or people cheering fellow members of the team, that's a cheap form of group identity. It's not as real as religion or something that is in much more long-standing. But in a way, all of our group loyalties are probably shaped by similar forces, small accidental events that over time become the pillars of our lives. Yes. When we think of identities, it's probably best to just start small, find any common ground you can with somebody, and then you need to build on that, by having them work together or something bigger, and maybe competing against other groups
通过让他们为更伟大的事情而共同努力。也许以一种不具破坏性或危险性的方式与其他群体竞争，或者至少拥有共同的目标感。如果你想看到我们社会中最具种族和谐的环境，它们往往是完全实现种族融合并像兄弟姐妹一样共同努力实现共同目标的职业运动队。
in a way that's not harmful or dangerous, or at least having a common sense of purpose. by having them work together for something bigger. And maybe competing against other groups in a way that's not harmful or dangerous, or at least having a common sense of purpose. If you wanna see the most racially harmonious environments in our society, they're often professional sports teams that are completely racially integrated and work together as brothers or sisters
是的，我也在体育比赛中看到了这一点。当你的球队获胜时，人们此时根本不会在意，你知道的，我是在拥抱一个黑人，还是在拥抱一个白人，还是一个年长的人，或者来自不同宗教的人？团队的群休身份现在超越了所有这些其他先前的群体身份。是的，这是人们需要了解的最重要的事之一。你可以在群体之间制造分裂，但如果你们为了某个共同的目标（无论是在体育运动中还是在工作中）而建立支持和共同努力，那些原本剑拔弩张的群体也可以被凝聚在一起，让人们投入其中、作出牺牲并在群体所有成员之间建立友谊，从而克服那些敌意。因此，这似乎是关于人性的深层特征，不仅仅是我们会在冲突中形成群体，
towards achieving common goals together. Yeah, and I've seen this at sports games as well. When your team wins, people are not paying attention at this point. You know, am I hugging somebody who's black, or am I hugging someone who's white, or someone who's older, or from a different religion? The group identity to the team now supersedes all of those other previous group identities. Yeah, this is one of the most important things for people to know. You can create division between groups, but those same groups who are at each other's throats, if you create a support and a goal
而且我们还可以形成更广泛、更具包容性的群体。杰伊，我们在谈话早些时候谈到了警察与平民社区之间的一些冲突，特别是在涉及对种族 profiling（种族定性）的担忧时。有一些研究探讨了在某种程度上使警察队伍多元化如何能够产生减少其中一些偏见的效果。你能谈谈其中一些工作吗？即在某种程度上
that they're working towards something together, whether it's in sports or at work, that can pull people together and get people committed and making sacrifices and building friendships among all members of their group in a way that can overcome those animosities. And so this seems to be something deep about human nature, it's not just that we form groups in conflict,
通过重塑群体，你正在重塑群体身份，然后你也在重塑感知和行为？是的，芝加哥有引人入胜的研究，他们试图了解你可以做些什么来改善警务工作。关于这一点最令人印象深刻的研究之一是一项大规模的宏观研究。他们发现，警官队伍日益多元化对警察行为产生了重大影响。具体而言，黑人和西班牙裔警官与白人警官相比，进行的拦截和逮捕次数更少，使用武力的频率也低得多。在他们与黑人平民互动时，这一点尤其明显。
but that we can form even broader groups that are more inclusive. We talked earlier in the conversation, Jay, about some of the conflicts that police were having with civilian communities, especially when it came to concerns about racial profiling. There have been studies sort of looking at how diversifying the police force in some ways can have the effect of reducing some of these biases. Can you talk about some of that work, the idea that in some ways
因此，这就是为什么代表性——拥有一群多元化的人负责无论是警务还是管理其他组织——是绝对至关重要的原因。我认为许多美国人都记得9-11袭击之后的那些日子，当时整个国家显然正在经历一个非常阴郁的时期，但发生的事情之一是，国家内部的许多党派分歧在几周内烟消云散了。人们首先把自己视为美国人，而不是共和党人或民主党人。所以我认为这是另一个例子，展示了在某种程度上，
by reshaping the groups, your reshaping group identities, and you're also then reshaping perception and behavior? Yes, so there's fascinating research in Chicago where they've tried to understand what you can do to improve policing. And one of the most impressive studies on this was a massive large scale study. They found that increasingly diversity of police officers made a significant difference in police behavior. And so black and Hispanic officers in particular made fewer stops and arrests and used force far less often than white officers. And this was especially true when they interacted with black civilians.
危机或某种威胁如何能导致人们超越狭隘的群体身份，看向更宏大的事物。对于如何基本上利用群体身份的科学，来克服我们在美国以及许多其他国家看到的某些党派分歧，你有什么想法？一些真正伟大的领导人有能力将人们团结在共同的身份周围。因此，这不仅可以发生在美国，也可以发生在许多其他国家。一些真正伟大的领导人有能力将人们团结在共同的身份周围。
And so this is one of the reasons why representation, having a diverse group of people who are in charge of whether it's policing or her running other organizations, is incredibly essential. So many Americans, I think, remember the days after the 9-11 attacks when obviously the country was going through a very somber period, but one of the things that happened is that many of the partisan divisions in the country melted away for a few weeks. People thought of themselves as Americans first, not as Republicans or Democrats. So I think that's another example of how, in some ways,
因此，这既可以发生在面临来自其他国家的威胁时，也可以发生在当你们对超越所有人的宏大事物拥有共同目标时。因此，这是太空竞赛的一部分。无论我们是否加入，太空探索都将继续前进。这是有史以来最伟大的冒险之一。
a crisis or some kind of a threat can cause people to look beyond a narrow group identity to something larger. What ideas would you have to essentially, you know, from the science of group identity, to overcome some of the partisan divisions we're seeing in the United States, but also in many other countries? Some really truly great leaders are capable of rallying people around a common identity. And so this can happen in the United States, but also in many other countries. Some really truly great leaders are capable of rallying people around a common identity.
那是在冷战期间，但肯尼迪试图做的是让人们围绕一个共同的有远见的目标团结起来。我们能把人送上月球吗？这产生了巨大的兴奋。因此，这正是我们政治日常演变中所经常缺少的东西，我们的政治通常只关乎党派利益。我们真的需要思考，究竟是什么能够激发、振奋并激励人们感受到共同的目标感，去做出牺牲并互帮互助，
And so this can happen in the face of threat from other countries, but can also happen when you have a shared purpose about something that's bigger than everybody. And so this is part of the space race. The exploration of space will go ahead whether we join in it or not. And it is one of the great adventures of all time.
远离在网络上或其他形式的媒体上对彼此进行网络钓鱼或互相恶搞。你知道的，你刚才提到了太空竞赛。宇航员威廉·安德斯（William Anders）在1968年拍摄了一张著名的照片。它被称为《地出》（Earthrise），照片显示一颗脆弱的蓝色星球悬挂在太空浩瀚的黑暗中。以下是威廉·安德斯对看到月球地平线上的地球时的感受的描述
And that was during the Cold War, but what Kennedy tried to do was get people around a common visionary purpose. Can we put somebody on the moon? And that generated an enormous amount of excitement. And so this is something that is often missing from the way that our politics normally unfolds, which is really about partisan gain. We really need to think about like, what is gonna animate and excite and motivate people to feel a common sense of purpose, to make sacrifices and help on another,
来到月球地平线，我立刻几乎被这种想法所淹没。我们大老远来到月球，然而我们看到的最重要的东西却是我们自己的家园星球——地球。杰伊，你认为这位宇航员的经历向我们传达了什么信息，关于我们重新思考群体身份以克服不仅在地方层面或国家层面，而且像气候变化威胁这样的全球性问题所具有的潜力。为了解决像气候变化这样全人类的问题，我们需要达到
move away from trolling one another online or in other forms of media. You know, you mentioned the space race a second ago. The astronaut William Anders took a famous photograph in 1968. It's called Earthrise and it shows a delicate blue planet suspended in the vast blackness of space. Here's how William Anders described what it felt like to see the Earth over the horizon
前所未有的国际合作水平。这些宇航员的经历表明这是可能的。许多从高空俯瞰过地球的宇航员的采访都有这种对全人类的敬畏感和连结感，许多地球，阿波罗8号的乘组有一条我们想传达给您的信息。起初，上帝创造了天地。地球将无力地移动。让每个人都去月球是不切实际的，但它表明，如果我们能让人把自己视为与全人类相连，我们或许就能改变他们对自己想法的看法。
of the moon. Coming upon the lunar horizon, I was immediately almost overcome with this thought. Here we came all this way to the moon, and yet the most significant thing we are seeing is our own home planet, the Earth. Jay, what do you think this astronaut's experience tells us about the potential we have to rethink our group identities to overcome problems not just at the local level or the national level, but global problems like the threat of climate change. To address a problem like climate change, we need a level of international cooperation
他们突然认为自己是更宏大事物的一部分，是比他们的国家更宏大事物的一部分。这可能是我们需要采取的触发因素，以激励人们为共同的目标努力，去击退将影响我们所有人的威胁。地平线上最大的威胁，在我们度过大流行之后，最大的威胁就是气候变化。
we've never seen before. And the experience of these astronauts suggests it's possible. Many interviews with astronauts who've ever seen the Earth from above have this experience of awe and connectedness with all of humanity, and many Earth, the crew of Apollo 8 has a message that we would like to send you. At the beginning, God created the heaven and the earth. The earth will move without force. It's not feasible for us to get everybody up to the moon, but what it suggests is that if we can get people to see themselves as connected to all of humanity, we might be able to change the way they think about themselves.
这将是一场海啸。我们已经看到了它的影响。因此，这确实需要每个人、每个国家之间有共同的目标感，因为如果我们失去了这个地球，我们就无处可去了。心理学家杰凡·巴维尔（Javan Bavill）和多米尼克·帕克（Dominic Packer）是《我们的力量：利用我们的共享身份来提高绩效、增加合作并促进社会和谐》（The power of us, harnessing our shared identities to improve performance, increase cooperation and promote social harmony）的作者。杰伊，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我。
They suddenly see themselves as part of something bigger, part of something bigger than their nation. And it might be the trigger that we need to motivate people to work towards common purpose, to fight off the threats that are gonna affect all of us. And the biggest one on the horizon, the moment we're done with the pandemic, the biggest threat is climate change.
《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们今天的无名英雄是安娜·温（Anna Wynn）。安娜在苹果工作，过去几年里，她从关于苹果播客应用的技术问题到如何与新听众更好地建立联系的想法等各种事情上都给予了我们帮助。谢谢你，安娜，感谢你的所有帮助以及你的奉献和无限耐心。如果您喜欢今天的节目并且喜欢我们的工作，请考虑支持我们。
It's going to be a tsunami. We're already seeing the effects of it. And so it really does require a sense of common purpose among everyone, among every country, because if we lose this earth, we don't have anywhere to go. Psychologists, Javan, Bevel, and Dominic Packer are the authors of the power of us, harnessing our shared identities to improve performance, increase cooperation and promote social harmony. Jay, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. Good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, good night, Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our
您可以通过访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 来做到这一点。再次强调，那是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。
executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Anna Wynn. Anna works at Apple and over the past few, she's helped us with all kinds of things from technical questions about the Apple Podcast app to ideas about how to connect better with new listeners. Thank you, Anna, for all your help and for your dedication and endless patience. If you enjoyed today's show and you like our work, please consider supporting us.
执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行主编。我们今天的无名英雄是安娜·温。安娜在苹果公司工作，在过去的这段时间里，她从关于苹果播客应用的技术问题到如何更好地与新听众建立联系的想法，在各方面都给予了我们帮助。谢谢你，安娜，感谢你所有的帮助、奉献和无尽的耐心。如果你喜欢今天的节目并且喜欢我们的工作，请考虑支持我们。
You can do so by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 来进行支持。再次强调，是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。回头见。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。